next up we have the spider that bit
Miles Morales otherwise known as the
alcamex radioactive spider this was a
spider labeled number 42 from the
company alchemax this spider bit him in
the sewer as he was making some graffiti
art and it's based on oscorp's number 42
spider from the Ultimate Comics
spider-gwen is based on Earth 65 in the
comics where Gwen Stacy was bit by the
spider instead of Peter Parker at a
young age Gwen was bitten by a
radioactive spider and using her
Newfound spider-like abilities to fight
crime became known as Spider-Woman up
next is spider Noir based on Earth 90214
in the comics which was characterized
with more mystical elements in this
version Peter broke an antique spider
Idol that released a horde of spiders
and one of them bit him then a spider
God visited him in his dream granting
him Powers next up is Penny Parker based
on Earth 14512 in the comics in which a
radioactive spider bit Penny Parker
creating a telepathic link between Penny
and the spider robot suits computer
allowing her to Pilot it next we have
spider ham based on Earth 8311 in the
comics where Peter was originally a
spider and was actually bit by a
radioactive Pig